[Music]
good evening unemployment claimants who
say they're victims of fraud continue to
contact eight news now just desperate
for answers
thanks for joining us here at six i'm
denise feldick i'm david charns in for
brian tonight
now last night we showed you how dieter
is working to verify
people's identities who have their
accounts closed and right now at six our
joe mohler is live with the other
issues people are having problems with
joe
well david there's two major parts of
this the first part is
people trying to get their accounts uh
reopened some of them are frozen so now
they're working with
dieter to get there to get a hold of
their benefits now the second part of
this is people
are just trying to get that money that
was allegedly stolen out of their
accounts back
i've had the 475 that's in the account
plus
two more deposits totaling 938 dollars
that's in limbo richard swayze is yet
another person who says he had
unemployment benefits stolen from his
account
they shut it down thinking that if they
replace the funds
it would go right back into the
compromised account that
the money was taken from he is working
to get that account reopened through
dieter while
trying to get the stolen money back i
just can't let that go i mean that's
that's money that you know i'm entitled
to
i contacted bank of america wednesday
they tell me claimants should call the
number on the back of their car to
report the claim
that could take 10 business days to
investigate you should report the fraud
regardless if your account
is frozen and always report the
transaction to police
swayze says he was told something a
little different
i stayed in touch with them left and
right you know given them the police
report that i had filed
and they said that i just had to bear
with it could take up to 90 days
after noticing a pattern with the debit
cards we contacted metro to see if they
are noticing anything
they tell me they don't necessarily
break down unemployment cards into a
separate category
they did tell me recently a handful of
card skimmers were collected around the
valley
on the metro financial crimes page they
provided pictures
of the skimmers and what people should
look out for when using cars
[Music]
and if you wanted to take a closer look
at those tips regarding those skimmers
we have a link to that facebook post up
on our website eightnewsnow.com and
still tonight
we are waiting to hear back from bank of
america america regarding a number of
claims
we have sent them reporting live joe
mohler eight news now